if you or someone you know has high
blood pressure this video will show you
some ways to manage it
in most cases the cause of high blood
pressure or hypertension is unknown this
type of high blood pressure is called
primary or essential hypertension
treatment for it includes lifestyle
changes such as eating a healthy diet
if you are sensitive to the sodium in
salt your doctor may tell you to eat
less salt and processed foods sodium may
cause your body to retain water this
increases the amount of your blood and
makes your blood pressure go up
other lifestyle changes can lower your
blood pressure they include not drinking
too much alcohol
getting regular exercise
losing weight if you need to
and quitting smoking
your doctor may also recommend
medications that act on your kidneys
blood vessels
or heart to help lower your blood
pressure
diuretics commonly called water pills
cause your kidneys to move more salt and
water from your blood into your urine
this reduces both the amount of your
blood and your blood pressure
beta-blockers reduce the workload on
your heart in two ways
they slow your heartbeat and lower the
force of each beat
several types of drugs lower your blood
pressure by relaxing your blood vessels
this makes them open up wider
these drugs include ACE inhibitors
angiotensin 2 receptor blockers
calcium-channel blockers
and direct-acting vasodilators
it is important to stay on your
medications as directed even if you are
feeling better do not go off your
medication unless your doctor tells you
to if you have any questions about any
medications you have been prescribed
speak with your doctor